I'm thrilled to have here to chronicle
the life and times of the great Don
Shula a man who is known Don for a very
long time knew him for ever and a day
and is as expert on South Florida sports
as anybody that I know and thrill to
have be back here on the Rich Eisen show
a man who normally would be here on this
Monday talking about all the Derby
winners that he got for all of our
friends and listeners on the program the
great Hank Goldberg how are you Hank
rich huh I know the tough day for those
of us who were close to coach you you
talk about horse racing in his later
years once a month he and I and Bob
Griese a couple other fellows will go to
Gulfstream for lunch and I did the
handicapping of course and he was as
demanding on me as he was on his players
because he didn't like favorite see you
he said I don't want any chalk but I'd
yeah he liked the win but he didn't want
it to be easy well I mean in plus he's
used to as you know a head coach winning
67 percent of the time now I don't know
if that happens in horse racing either
thank you know so when somebody
certainly of a certain age right here
who may not remember the great dolphin
years or associate the Dolphins with
perennial winning every year year in and
year out who was Don Shula who would use
what would you tell that person of that
generation who Don Shula was Hank well
he was a very demanding coach but his
players still you know loved them and he
was you know he said something to me
once we were talking about a coach who
had a tough year and then let go of his
staff and he said there was something he
would never do because the buck always
stopped with him he knew everything that
was going on with that team I mean
everything that happened in that locker
room he was on top of and he was he knew
every detail and he left nothing but it
was not attended to and that was him and
he he just
was always prepared and he always did
things the right way and he was never
any scandal with him
nobody ever suspected him of anything
that wasn't on the up-and-up he was just
a great great guy at what he did
and what it was it was yeah I'm sorry no
no it's okay go for it dang I was gonna
say he was so respected in the community
that one is that when Miami was having
problems with riots and the reputation
was was besmirched and they formed the
committee and they were looking for
somebody to be the chairman of the
committee who the world respected they
turned the Shuler and he became the
honorary chairman of they're trying to
get their image restored that's what
they thought of them well I mean
obviously I guess the 17 in no season
would be the pinnacle for him and just
the the the Brotherhood the fraternity
that that seemed to to spark for decades
that they everyone would still get
together that is just something for me
that was always just remarkable to see
certainly in this day and age where I
guess people can grow apart and I'm
wondering how much schule had to do with
all of that thank uh well that was
something that some of the players who
live close to each other used to get
together and celebrate but you know they
had reunions I went to one just a few
years ago and you know he was always
there they had a person who was in
charge of man that Moore was in charge
of of the alumni and they made sure that
everybody was in touch that they would
all come in and and and meet
periodically every few years to
celebrate their accomplishment and it
was a wonderful event to attend and
coach you always spoke and of course the
guy
always brought the house down with
stories was Larry Csonka who was really
Sheila's favorite you know what those
lunches that we had in later years his
memory was sharp he could remember
things that were just amazing his days
with the Colts asked him once about
Unitas and he said well the best athlete
on that team was Lenny more he was
probably the best athlete I ever coached
kind of an astounding thing for him to
say when you think about all the great
athletes he coached although he
acknowledged that war feat was probably
the best guy he coached athletic wise
with the dolphins but you know and he
would tell stories about Otto Graham
when Cleveland and he and he was just
and he and Greece he would get into a
little bit because he remembers every
play and a greasy called
all right and you know greasy did call
his own place although you know Shula
dictated what they were gonna be thank
you there did I lose you think yeah okay
Hank Goldberg here on the Rich Eisen
show okay so hulking ladder I mean stuff
like that fake spike these are all or
these all things that jeweler would be
you know the idea man for or he would be
people that he delegated to because
that's what he did I I just would love
to get before I let you go some of the
nuts and bolts and some of the best
memories yeah for some of the most
memorable plays in the history of the
NFL
well hook-and-ladder was his was his
play the Marino play was Marino but you
know he was he had you know people who
coached against him so that he was a
difficult guy to coach against because
he took every game separately and you
know but you know he was adaptable I
thought one of the more amazing things
about him was he threw the ball only
seven times
and and one of the super bowls would
greasy not that there was anything wrong
wrong with greasy who had Warfield
Howard twirly Jim man has had some good
receivers but then Marino came along and
he changed his whole philosophy and he
really was the forerunner of today's
offenses when he had Marino and Cooper
and Clayton and that more and you know
some of those tight ends crashed Jensen
out of the backfield those were all
things that he developed along with his
assistant Gary Stevens but it was all
Shue who saw what he had with Marino and
changed his entire coaching philosophy
and if you look at what they do today
they look at films of what Marino did
and that's what they used so before I
let you go Hank how do you think Don
Shula would want to be remembered I
think he would want to Remember Who as a
coach who did everything the right way
and you know the fact that his players
responded to him and but I think he he
really appreciated the fact that that he
could not just say that he could win but
the way he won that was important to him
Hank I appreciate the time everything
else okay in your world family good yes
good yeah I'm still working at it doing
some handicapping for ESPN numbers I saw
on all day Saturday and I thought I
would have given you a nice $89 exactly
I love it you said Shula didn't want any
favorites he wanted no chauka
he wanted he wanted a hit that one you
want to hit the big one yeah he used to
get on me about that and he said when we
get to the track we sit down for lunch
and he said chok chok chok and had his
birthday celebration a couple years ago
right before I move that here yeah
I said 80 or 88 when you what do you
want for would you want for your
birthday he said I'd like to become 89
well he did he got to become 90 days
really you know boy that one just hit me
in the gut there Hank for you to say
yeah you know and you know as far as
what happened to him this was not virus
related but he had some back problems he
was sore the last couple of days and he
was sleeping a lot and apparently he
just died in his sleep he I it may have
been the beginning stages of a pneumonia
but I'm not sure about that well he went
last summer he organized a trip with it
with his wife for 24 people to go to a
Norman Braman shot and sail around
Europe and you know right till the end
he loved to travel and he loved being
around his friends and and that was
important to him so he was a very loyal
man and he was able to enjoy that that
summer and as you said get to see 90 and
then pass away in his sleep in a in a
peaceful manner yeah you know one other
thing you know I talked to him about a
month ago and you know I'm getting
treatment for you know for kidney
disease which had gone very well by the
way great to hear but he always asked me
first how are you doing you know all the
issues that he had physically he always
cared about me and when I when I got
fired from my job at the radio station
when I was podcasting their games
because I had a beef with a programming
director can you imagine that and I went
to tell him right away and he knew about
it and he called me into his office and
opened up a couple of cans of beers we
spent an hour together when I walked out
of there I felt great about myself and I
knew then you know way he could handle
people and my first assignment for ESPN
was to cover them at the Meadowlands
when they were facing two Jets he got
off the team bus saw me with the mic
flag and he came over he said
smile on his face I told you you'd do
well Hank love you man
thank you for taking the time and
helping us remember your friend and my
condolences and same from Susan tattoos
thanks Chris all my best to Susie we'll
simply thank you thanks for the call
that's Hank Goldberg sailed around the
world that's the way you want to do it
oh god I'm just getting home I want a
way to go sail around the world with
your wife and friends passing his sleep
rest in peace Don Shula rest in peace to
the all-time winningest head coach in
the National Football League but as you
hear from so many those who knew him and
trip paid tribute to him a great human
being and a winner of life Don Shula
passing away at the age of 90 we say
rest in peace to the all-time great